here are some tests that I play on men
in order to see if they're going to be
able to provide and protect me because
if they're not I don't
think then you shouldn't either thing
first him paying for the day let's just
stop this conversation in the back and
forth 50 50. first date he needs to be
paying 100 and if it's not then like
goodbye it comes with an example this
weekend went out to the bar in Miami and
I ran into someone that I had been
following on Instagram so we hung out
for most of the night and then as we
were leaving we both had Ubers going
separate because Uber came first and
he's like oh no I'll wait for you me and
my head I'm like oh no like you don't
have to wait for me being kind whatever
and this man gets into his Uber and
takes off
it is 4 am in Miami Florida
where no good is to come everything is
shut down and I'm standing by myself in
the middle of the street
immediately now immediately no if you
don't care about my safety and making
sure that I get into my Uber safely
you're done you're done for it and then
if you don't go ahead and double check I
made it safely
bye this van failed my production test
so he never heard from me again men you
need to be walking her to her car to her
Uber to wherever to make sure she gets
home safely
um the double checking to making sure
that you made it home safely is really
just something that you feel it feels so
good I like it feels so good for you to
hear but let's really think about it if
you get home and I'm like are you home
and I get no answer and you did there's
nothing I can do carry on
it's really just to make you feel good
but at that point I'm home and my boxers
probably jerking off and you did
there's nothing I could do
checking out after it makes you feel
good it makes me feel good but if we're
really honest about this [ __ ] there's
nothing I can do if you have an accident
I can't run up to this [ __ ] and know
like a location or whatever or know
what's going on you don't answer you
don't answer something happened it's
only good if nothing happens if
something really happened
what what I do it's like hey it's uh
it's like Let Me Wait For You with the
car no no I'll be fine
all right if you if you say so
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and then people really and then you're
gonna she's gonna be the same girl
that's gonna be talking about I hate
when they give mixing signals
[Laughter]
the one you're not the one don't this
girl said he failed my protection test
[ __ ] you failed this sanity test uh
because you said I'm crazy there's a
thing that people use to communicate
things to each other they're called
words
if you use them effectively you can get
your point across to people you'd be
surprised you might actually get what
you want if you just ask so you're going
to run tests so go in a restaurant be
like I want a double cheeseburger you
traditionally get the double
cheeseburger if I got to give a word a
mess out there don't run tests
don't run tests don't test people it's
like the people who say
okay when we go I'll pay but I want her
to offer to go pay half and half because
if she don't I don't show a gold digger
you don't actually do it but you have to
oh [ __ ] oh my God you guys just want a
posture everybody wants to do some kind
of [ __ ] this way uh my foot's going
ears your food God isn't going there
we doing a Cha-Cha come on bro just use
your words yeah let's I'll get mad when
I see stuff like this I'm gonna get mad
I don't get in Craigslist I just laugh
because I'm like
you doing the most like this could
actually save your ass you realize
you're the last person she's seen with
if she goes missing
if she goes missing there's other ways
of knowing that you know I mean boy are
the cops gonna come and be like so
you're the last person seen with Miss
Reyes um
see if she got home safely no lock him
up buddy look him up put him behind you
oh What's It Gonna protect us for I
checked in the [ __ ] didn't answer have
you I didn't do it if I'm driving at you
I'm driving you at your house I'm
driving around your house all right and
I I you're getting it I'm gonna wait
till you get in your house because
you're in the streets treats and you're
right there that'd be but I'm there
texting ain't gonna do [ __ ] hey man did
you go home safely it doesn't do [ __ ] I
I do it but like my siblings and [ __ ]
like that but really there's nothing I
could do the only thing I could do and
most people do that yo
did you get home safe or text me when
you get home and it's like there's more
they're not gonna stay up to wait for
the [ __ ] to say no it's like
did you get home safe baby wake up in
the morning and like oh okay I got home
safe sorry I passed out okay cool
everybody go to sleep come on now we
don't lose sleep over this there's
nothing you could do another inviting
test that I do is when we're out if you
have like a jacket on or like some kind
of like over
shirt I will always without a doubt say
that I'm cold
because I want to see if you will give
me the shirt off your back and if you
don't
you're done to me I'm testing you too
I'm testing you too I'm cold you should
have got out with something hotter on
your shoulders you know damn do you have
a phone do you know what you get to
count you get the temperature Shadow and
[ __ ] the Channel network and everything
and stuff you knew what the weather was
why did you put that you knew it was
about to be a little bit windy yeah
because then you make poor decisions I
could be running tests too I could be
like hey
if she asked me to put the shirt on my
back it means that we're gonna suffer
I'm gonna always have to I could we
could do the same mental gymnastic which
makes no sense and do that too imagine
going to such links to try to test a guy
that you're gonna go outside in a skimpy
ass outfit freezing out there catching a
cold just so you contestant dude imagine
catching a cold so you could test
something not a guy is dead to you now
you just cold horny and sick and you
know what you advertise with this whole
video to most men out there this [ __ ]
is difficult yeah that's all that we got
from this not that you have standards
you just difficult and that's your
independent ass needs to rely on a man
that's you're doing the opposite right
now come on now B you're not helping
yourself as soon as this girl talk about
tests
[ __ ] I'm out of school for a reason I
ain't trying to go back
who leaves school and says I want more
tests who
I left my mama crib and I need another
mother like being obnoxious and [ __ ] nah
be obnoxious you you're being difficult
if you do
I won't take it because toes don't get
cold
you see a hoes don't get cold you're
crazy
you're you're crazy
you're you're crazy oh that's great oh
you know uh crazy is really appointed
the woman that's crazy
that's not saying
that's playing games and then you're
gonna talk about men don't know what
they want
and they're sending mixed signals well
do the comments say I mean they're mixed
some of the people agree some of them
don't of course you know the funny thing
is like she like this guy Instagram and
they happen to be at the same spot so
they decide to like spend some time
eating and stuff like that I don't know
it's just something funny about like
somebody you don't really know that well
barely know not even like talked a long
time romantically or anything like that
and be like hey you made it home safely
like I don't know to me it's just
and the guy's probably not even
interested in you what's your running
tests someone wrote someone wrote you
told him to go ahead don't play games
and you two weren't on a date and she
says what's your point holy [ __ ]
that's the point you weren't even
mistake
they weren't even on a date she's
testing this [ __ ] testing
everybody knock knock excuse me sir is
it your Abba yeah we need to test you
for uh anti-doping because you know
they're the Olympics coming we need to
test you but I'm not going to the
Olympics what's your point come on let's
go
I'm not even
I'm not going to the Olympics I'm not
even in the Canadian team you want to
test me that's what you look like that's
what you're doing it's like what Chris
Rock said about Jada when she said she's
boycotting the Oscars you're not invited
how can you eat from outside the club
you can't even get in
we'll see what you want about Chris
that's a legendary laugh it is
yeah I just hear about some of this
stuff I just roll my eyes man that's
just maybe it's because I'm getting
older
it's just like I see nonsense I just
roll my eyes online a [ __ ] I ain't got
time today it's a hundred I don't care
if you got an ass like whoever I don't
care if you got titties like Pamela
Anderson or prom I don't care you're
difficult none of that [ __ ] is worth any
of this nonsense I ain't the one oh for
all that I'm not the dude I don't care I
don't care so all I hear you is a
headache yeah difficult ugh don't don't
matter host come regret instantly
guaranteed post come regret oh yeah yeah
once you take out the big goggles you
already know what time it is so I don't
even do it anymore I I got I got the
[ __ ] I I have big fishes
dick goggles that's the image that
[ __ ] gonna get no and I think I
was something I know what it is but I
mean when you say it it's like beer
goggles testosterone you know beer
goggles are testosterone goggles that's
dig goggles come on testoster is too
long nobody use no words like that
[ __ ] estrogen goggles nobody uses it
okay goggles beer goggles you know what
those are yeah I know what that is the
word goggle sounds kind of gay no but
goggle
my Domino's well you should have put it
in there yeah
you pushed me yeah
I was testing your balance
and you failed you failed [ __ ] your dog
but that's exactly it but I failed yeah
[Music]
congratulations you won Hey guys you're
watching today's video